so here is a headline from CBS this
morning quote undocumented transgender
woman filing domestic violence claim
arrested L at El Paso courthouse by ice
official says the ultimate victim we
found the ultimate victim an illegal
immigrant transgender woman abused by a
domestic partner deported for the crime
of showing up to a courthouse stop the
presses here's some other media
headlines about the horrifying story ice
detains domestic violence victim in El
Paso Court Huffington Post ice
reportedly detained a domestic abuse
victim who sought court protection
Newser ice agents arrest woman in
domestic violence court New York
magazine I used to arrest domestic
violence victim at Texas Court House the
washington post this is really
unprecedented ice detains woman seeking
domestic abuse protection at texas
courthouse even Fox News ice agents
reported arrest alleged domestic
violence victim at Texas courthouse now
here's how the headline should actually
have read ice agents arrest repeatedly
convicted criminal 4z portation at
courthouse the transgender woman in
question has been deported six times
before and voluntarily returned to
Mexico one other time here is the rap
sheet for the transgender woman from
2013 assault probation violence domestic
violence false imprisonment of a minor
that information which seems sort of
important it's buried in the second to
last paragraph of a nineteen paragraph
CBS news story The Washington Post
buried it in it buried it in paragraph
10 The Huffington Post didn't mention it
at all all of the stories mentioned a
comment from the county prosecutor who
said that ice knew about the deportees
location because of an anonymous tip the
prosecutor suggested the tip came from
the alleged domestic abuser but admitted
she had no specific information that
would lead her to that conclusion there
are provisions by the way in US law that
apparently prevents the rest of someone
for immigration status based solely on
reports from domestic abuser but you
don't get the whole story from the media
particularly not from their headlines
the crusade is now on to find victims of
the supposedly Gestapo esque Trump
immigration enforcement policy and the
media won't let inconvenient facts like
repeat criminality of the arrested
stands in the way i'm ben shapiro this
is a venture puro show
you
it's mailbag day yeah we're going to get
to the mailbag today everybody is very
excited about all of it but we will get
to that in just a second first we have
to say thank you so our advertisers over
at Zeile so if you are somebody who is
desperately in need of us out of massage
and I am one of these people I will
admit I get very stressed and and I
require massages from time to time veal
is the place where you go to zeile calm
and you and you can get a massage at
your half they come to your house they
cater to you and you can choose the kind
of masseuse that you want the type of
massage it's on demand it's at home well
you try it out actually my mother-in-law
came into town and I was supposed to get
the massage from zeal and instead
because I was a good son-in-law I gave
it to my mother in law our relationship
has never been better it worked out
great our listeners get twenty five
dollars off their first massage by using
the promo code been at checkout at Zeile
calm right now it costs about on average
twenty to fifty percent less and if you
go to a local spot or hotel plus you
don't have to actually go there and wait
for an appointment you actually make the
appointment online on the on the app and
then they come to your house and the
masseuses are absolutely first-rate it's
like bringing the spa into your house
they bring all of the all of the
materials and bring the table they bring
the descent and hands of the whole deal
laboring ok its zeal it's called z ee l
calm and make sure to click the add
promo code at checkout to use my promo
clip been you get twenty five dollars
off your first massage zo calm or you
can go to their iphone or android app to
get that special offer when you try to
deal today they about 8,000 massage the
massage therapists all over the country
again use that promo code been a check
out to get twenty-five percent $25 off
your first massage they are the first
and leading same day in-home massage
company and i can vouch for their
quality because as I say my
mother-in-law has never been happy for
having stolen a massage that was
allotted to me in any case we begin so
lots of good Trump lots of bad Trump
Donald Trump has been a very very busy
president over the last 2 24 hours so we
begin so we begin okay so let's start
with the let's play the good from bad
something we haven't done that in a in
at least three hours lets you that
[Music]
which one will begin yes indeedy do it's
time for some good Trump antrim and
who's coming who's got boom it's good
trunk yes he's back so after a week of
stupidity about michael Flynn we now
actually get some good Trump and not
just good Trump great from this is the
best that Trump has a look in his
presidency since he took meal or such
here's where Trump is actually really
good when Trump has these sort of pre
scheduled events with people that he
likes and he gets to play the triumphant
Conqueror great great you know Neal
Gorsuch that event was beautifully
staged beautifully managed to handle
themselves well and then he did it with
Benjamin Netanyahu the Prime Minister of
Israel yesterday Sanditon yahoo shows up
after eight long years of being out in
the cold thanks to President Barack I'm
not real fond of them Jews Obama and you
know his his anti-israel policy is
really egregious mean I talked about
this for years when President Obama was
president now Donald Trump has come into
office nobody really knows where he is
on any of these issues he's made
overtures that make him sound very
pro-israel he's obviously been very warm
to our Bibi Netanyahu and yesterday
who's extremely warm for Bibi Netanyahu
he really reset the relationship I mean
it was the equivalent of handsome
Netanyahu a reset button he basically
said we're here for you we stand by you
we're not going to stand with terrorism
we're not going to stand alongside
radical Islamic terrorists just because
they have the the modifier Palestinian
by their name and so Donald Trump shows
up and he stands along this new yahoo
and you can see the warmth I mean listen
yahoo was so relieved he doesn't have to
deal with that jackass Obama and I mean
last I Obama's the kind of guy who was
making Netanyahu leave through the back
door and getting all ticked off of
Netanyahu spoke to a joint session of
Congress and putting severe pressure on
the Israelis at the very end of his
tenure through not gettin rid not
vetoing bad UN resolutions and so now
this now comes to the White House and
he's actually the red carpet is rolled
out for him and the event is really good
so here's here's Donald Trump talking
about a peace deal and he does something
that's pretty notable he doesn't talk
about the two-state peace deal he
doesn't talk about the idea of the
two-state solution which we'll talk
about in a second and I believe that the
great opportunity for peace comes from
a regional approach from involving our
newfound our partners in the pursuit of
a broader peace and peace with the
Palestinians and I greatly look forward
to discussing this in detail with you
mr. president because I think that if we
work together we have a shot and Trump
obviously agrees with that and so you
can see that in soon yahoo is really
really excited the Trump is there so
Trump himself didn't talk about the
two-state solution this is set to meet
you off why didn't he talk about the two
space because the two-state solution is
stupid I know it was stupid when I was
nine and they're doing me oswal cords it
turns out that giving terrorists estate
is not a good idea the Palestinian
Authority was a terrorist group it is a
terrorist group Hamas is a terrorist
group Islamic Jihad is a terrorist group
giving terrorists estate is a terrible
terrible terrible idea and when you say
we're making a peace deal and the peace
deal is going to be that at the end you
get a state you've already given up what
you're negotiating or there's no more
negotiation so why exactly what the
Palestinians give up anything at that
point why would they stop the terrorism
they know at the end points of this
negotiation is and they know that all
the pressure is on Israel to concede
things beyond that the stupidity of Oslo
was saying that the Palestinians have a
right to an independent state there is
no such historic right for the
Palestinians to have an independent
state that state was called Jordan
historically and when when they
partitioned British Mandate Palestine
there were there were two states right
they were originally there really only
two states in it was Jordan and Israel
and that was it and then they sliced off
another like Kwazii little state and
that was the the so-called West Bank and
Gaza Strip and the Arabs rejected that
deal there's no history to having
another in a second Palestinian state in
the region Jordan is seventy percent
Palestinian the idea that it was it was
a foregone conclusion the only way there
was ever going to be peace was to put a
terrorist group in charge of the West
Bank and Gaza Strip absolute stupidity
when the Jews pulled out of the Gaza
Strip it immediately was turned into
masa stand which is an actual terror
state and you know the fact that
everybody keeps glomming onto this to
state deal this two-state solution is
really dumb and it was really dumb for
the Israelis to do it because it was
basically suggesting that the Jews were
interlopers in the region that the Jews
had to make some sort of deal to give
away the heart of what it means to be
Jewish
in judea and samaria are the heart of
biblical israel giving away the heart of
biblical Israel to the Palestinian Arabs
suggests that they have a primacy of
historical claim that simply does not
exist oswell was foolish for that reason
historically morally politically in
abomination and finally recognizing that
after 25 years of failure seems like a
pretty good approach it seems like after
after doing this for two decades of
silliness maybe we should try something
else now there are a bunch of different
things that can be done here one could
be just a continuation of status quo
which is you don't get ship weapons in
you guys get to handle your own crap
internally and as long as there's no
terrorism we can have free flow of
people in and out of Palestinian areas
without granting independent statehood
that's not an apartheid state the United
States basically has that sort of
relationship with Puerto Rico Puerto
Rico isn't a sovereign country Puerto
Rico is still administered territory of
the United States technically they don't
get to vote in the presidential
elections they're not American citizens
but the United States actually helps out
in the administration of Puerto Rico and
so the suggesting that this is some sort
of apartheid state if they were to come
to this sort of arrangement is silly
there's also the caroline glick solution
which would be a one-state solution
which is basically Israel annexes
everything and then it's real actually
given citizenship to the Palestinians
because guess what there are six million
Jews in the area they're only with a
million and a half Palestinians and
that's not the world's biggest deal so
there's a plenty of solutions other than
we have to give an independent state to
a bunch of genocide all people who wish
to wipe shoes off the map it's always
funny they always talk about the Jews
participating in some sort of ethnic
cleansing effort by moving Palestinians
they never talk about the Palestinians
forcibly moving Jews down how many Jews
live in quote-unquote Palestine answer
is zero zero Jews lived there how many
Israeli Arabs live in Israel over a
million so the idea that the ethnic
cleansing is coming from the Jewish side
is really quite spectacularly stupid
getting rid of the the idea that the
Palestinians have to have their own
state as a precondition for any
negotiation is a good first step because
if you're actually going to have a
negotiation everything should be on the
table nothing should be off the table
the reason it's in yahoo wants to bring
in regional partners on the peace deal
is because he knows that Jordan doesn't
want to Palestinians you know the easy
of doesn't want to Palestinians he knows
the Saudis don't want the Palestinians
you know all of them oppose a
Palestinian state here's the reality
Egypt Jordan Saudi Arabia none of them
want a Palestinian state they all
pretend they do
for public consumption none of them
actually do the reason they don't
actually want that is because if there
are a Palestinian state on the border of
Jordan it would immediately become a
terrorist threat to Jordan itself and
the Egyptians don't want to Palestinian
terrorist state on their border they've
been having all sorts of border trouble
the the leader al Sisi has been having
all sorts of border trouble with with
Gaza scan with Ibaka masa Stan and Gaza
because Egypt is in control the Sinai
desert which runs all the way up to the
Gaza Strip so none of these countries
actually want there to be a Palestinian
state Netanyahu knows that that's why I
Netanyahu's saying we should have a
regional approach here listen listen yo
okay the Israeli government has a has a
on the table constant offer to the
Jordanians that if the Jordanians want
to take over all of the Palestinian
territories they can you know the
Jordanian sec they say no no one wants
to be in charge of this you know why
because it's filled with a terror
government okay so Netanyahu says all of
it and then Trump said something that's
not so good he says that that the
knitting yahoo should hold off on the
settlement and he doesn't in typical
kind of Trump Ian casual style here's
what he says as far as settlements I'd
like to see you hold back when
settlements for a little bit we'll work
something out but I would like to see a
deal be made I think a deal will be made
I know that every president would like
to most of them have not started too
late because they never thought it was
possible and it wasn't possible because
they didn't do it but BB and I have
known each other a long time a smart man
great negotiator and I think we're going
to make a deal okay so Trump me so so
this is the part that slightly
disquieting when Trump says things like
I know we're going to make a deal you
know I had well kind of pressure is he
going to bring to bear so far so good I
don't see a lot of pressure as far as
him mentioning the settlements I think
that he does so because the State
Department and people around him tell
him he has to mention the settlement so
he looks even handed it doesn't make a
lot of sense to say that the two-state
solution is not a precondition and
associations and then to say settlements
have to stop is really kind of silly
because the only reasons for settlements
to stop is the idea that you're
eventually going to transfer all of the
control over that territory to this this
growing terror state and its terror this
Palestinian terror state that's the only
reason you wouldn't want to use building
additional bathrooms on the back of
their houses or building more
settlements because the truth is the
Arabs in Palestine read the Arabs in the
Palestinian areas there's no pal
sign the Arabs in the Palestinian
control their of areas they would be
thrilled I mean realistically they'd be
thrilled with Israel would annex all the
territory their constant polls showing
that Israeli Arab given the option to
move to Palestinian territories or stay
in Israel they all want to stay in
Israel why because they have jobs
they're wealthy they live free and it
turns out that the area's control
Palestinians are kind of crap hole
because the administration there steals
billions of dollars from their own
people and takes all the foreign aid and
puts in their pocket Netanyahu obviously
is thrilled about all that she says look
we don't need a two-state solution that
ends with the terror state what does
that blue Mazda mean by two states okay
what does he mean a state that doesn't
recognize the Jewish state a state that
basically is open for attack against
Israel you know what are we talking
about we talking about Costa Rica are we
talking about another Iran so obviously
it means different things I told you
what are the conditions that I believe
are necessary for an agreement it's the
recognition of the Jewish state and its
Israel's Israel's security control of
the entire area otherwise we're just
fantasizing otherwise we'll get another
failed state and other terrorist
Islamist dictatorship that will not work
for peace but work to destroy us but
also destroy any hope any hope for a
peaceful future for our people okay and
all that yahoo says there is absolutely
one hundred percent true so you know
good good for good for Trump for taking
the blinders off with regard to this
idiotic two-state solution nonsense it's
time to move beyond failed failed
attempts of the past and time to talk
about realistic solutions in that area
realistic solutions will involve
security not peace but the security
that's going to be arranged is not going
to be on the back of setting up a terror
state in the heart of Israel that's
absolute solution is good for a
president Trump okay so we now have to
take our break over at Facebook and
YouTube but we have lots more coming up
we have to get two more of the fallout
about Flynn some bad Trump we have to
get to the media just making complete
fools of themselves the Republicans all
over them Sui have the mail bag so it
tons more coming up here on the bench
Shapiro shall go today lee weyer calm
right now to subscribe eight dollars a
month will buy you that subscription you
can see the rest of the show live you
can be part of the mailbag right now
doing the mailbag in just a few minutes
and you get to be part of it you get to
send in your questions live and I will
answer them live and make your life one
hundred percent better if your life is
crappy it will now be just glorious
it'll be utopia of happiness if your
life is already used hope you have
happiness well then I will send you
directly to heaven which mailbag so you
can go to daily wire calm right now
subscribe to annual subscribers get a
free copy of the arroyo fictional film
about what's happening down at the
southern border really good film about
the crisis on the southern border with
drug cartels coming across into Arizona
and what one Rancher does to stop it
daily wire calm is where you subscribe
or listen later in itunes and soundcloud
by the way we are now ranked overall in
the top 20 of all podcasts in the united
states not just political podcast in the
united states all podcasts in the united
states I think we're ranked as high as
14 on iTunes right now and climbing fast
so it's pretty pretty cool stuff we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
you